للنساء العزبات لا تحزن من تاخر الزواج
رساله وجهها داعيه الكويتيه والمستشار
الاسري مؤخرا واثاره الكثير من الجدل حيث
قال انه لا توجد امراه عانسبل امراه حفظها
الله من شر زواج سيء هذه تصريحات اثار
التساؤلات اي النساء اسعد المتزوجات ام
العازبات خاصه
عن الزواج سنه بعد سنه وارتفاع معدل سن
الزواج لدى الفتيات الى الثلاثينات
وارتفاعها لسه بالطلاق في المجتمعات
العربيه
وبين المشاكل والعلاقات الزوجيه غير
الناجحه هل يعتبر الزواج نعمه للفتيات ام
نقمه في عصرنا الحالي
[موسيقى]
قد لا تكون هناك حاجه لاجراء احصاءات
جديده لتبيان ارتفاع نسبه العزوبيه في
لبنان فهذا النسبه كانت الاعلى عربيا قبل
اعوام ولم تختفي باي حال اضرب هو العوامل
المسببه لها
[موسيقى]
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تقطع الطريق على
الشباب اللبناني امام تاسيس حياه زوجيه
وعائليه وتدفع بهم الى الهجره تاتي في
مقدمه هذه العوامل فضلا عن تكاليف عقود
الزواج ماذا فعل عام الماضي بمجموعه فتيات
الى اطلاق حمله وهشتاق تزوجني بدون مهر
والتاخر في سن الزواج مرضه لرغبه الشباب
ولا سيما نساء بتحقيق الذاتي والاستقلاليه
والامساك بزمام حياتهم اذ لم يعد مفهوم
السعاده بالمقاييس الحديثه مرتبطه حكما
بتاسيس عائله وبانجاب الاولاد
على ان الراغبات بالخيار الاخير بامكانهن
اللجوء الى عمليات تجميد البويضات التي
اصبحت رائجه للحفاظ على قدرتهم على الحمل
مستقبلانه
رجال قاعد بالبيت
يعني
العصر الحجري يعني كلمه
هذه الايام
نحنا بالقرن الواحد والعشرين المراه فيها
تعمل اكثر من الرجال
يعني
انس انه هذا من النهايه كله نصيب يعني بس
انه كلمه عانس هي كلمه مؤذيه وبالاخص
للمراه اكثر من الرجال
ونسبه العزوبيه او تاخر سنه الزواج او
كلاهما يفرضان تراجعا في نسبه الولاده
الامر الذي سيضع المجتمع اللبناني وفي مدى
قصير في خانه المجتمعات الهريمه لصباح
العربيه رينادوه بيروت
وللمفارقه معده التقرير متزوجه بثلاثه
ابناء الى لميس
مشروع الزواج يسجل تراجعا في اغلب الدول
العربيه منذ سنوات فبحسب مركز الخليج
العربي للدراسات والوقوف اللبنانيات حفظنا
على المرتبات الاولى في ترتيب اكثر
العربيات تاخرا في سن الزواج وذلك بنسبه
85%
التونسيات في المرتبه الثانيه بارتفاع
نسبه التاخر في سن الزواج الى نحو واحد
81% وبنسبه القدرت بين 70 الى 85% حل
الفرقيات في المرتبه الثالثه في نسبه
تقديريه بنحمل 70 الى 75% تاتي
الاماراتيات في المرتبه الرابعه اما
المرتبه الخامسه فكانت نصيب السوريات
بنسبه 70% وحاله المغربيه في المرتبه
السادسه بالنسبه
ارتفاع بنحو 20% خلال العقد الماضي
المرتبه السابعه من نصيب الاردنيات بنسبه
55% مع نسبه ارتفاع منهم 10% خلال العقل
الماضي ايضا اما الجزائريات فئتين في
المرتبه الثامنه بنسبه واحد 58% والمرتبه
التاسعه كانت نصيب المصريات بالنسبه كانوا
40%
السعوديات شاهدنا انخفاض في ترتيبهم الى
10% مقارنه بتقديرات 2013 ومن مصر ان
الناس هل ترين الفتاه العازبه في نعمه ام
نقمه من الحياه الزوجيه غير الناجحه متابع
[موسيقى]
انا مش شايفه ان انا ممكن
احط او ابقى شبه الخالي المئاته لمجرد ان
انا الناس تقول علي ايه ده دي متجوزه ايه
دي مخلفه ايه دي ده دي عملت اسره طب انا
فين
النجاح من نجاح الاخرين طب دي سنه الحياه
دي دي همم فكره ان انا الناس تشوفني درجه
ثانيه ان انا همم
عانس بالبلدي لا طبعا نعمه ان انا اقعد في
بيتي ما اتجوزش ولاني اتجوز جوازه مش تمام
مش كويسه الجوازه وبطله يعني
فالاحسن انا اقعد في بيتي معززه مكرمه مع
اهلي اللي يبهدلني اعتقد ان هي لو هي
متجوزتش احسن من لما تتجوز وحياه ابقى
تعيسه لان هي مع مع كمان ان هي هتبقى
تعيسه هي ورائها مسؤوليات طبعا الست
المتجوزه حتى لو هي متضايقه لازم تقوم
تعمل اللي وراها تشوف اولادها تشوف همم
جوزها محتاج ايه ف- يعني ما عندهاش
الرفاهيه بتاعه ان هي تبقى متضايقه وقاعده
لوحدها ما بتعملش حاجه بتفضي دماغها دي
نقطه من النقط طبعا التخليها لو هي في بيت
اهلها ده احسن لها من ان هي تبقى متجوزه
وتعيسه
[موسيقى]
المفروض ان العقليه بتاعه الاهلي نفسها هي
اللي بتتغير في المواقف اللي زي كده لان
طب يا فرحتي انا جوزت بنت بس هي متبهدله
او جوزها ده بيخونها ولا بيضربها يعني هي
فرحه قلبي هتبقى مبسوطه يعني في المنظر ده
اكيد
الطرفين باي طريقه
ولا لازم يبقى في مده تقريبا تقريبا فكره
ان ال اكس 4 دي وحشه قوي
بتجيب مشاكل بعد كده وعدم التفاهم وعدم
التفكير لازم الفكر لازم تفكرهم يبقى زي
بعض طالما يعني الفرصه اللي قدامها مش
كويسه لزواجها ياثر عليها بالسلب في
مستقبلها يبقى طبعا لا اختيار ان هي تفضل
عزبه احسن لها ومع كل سنه في عمرها بتعرف
تختار احسن
وهتحقق كمان اهدافها في الحياه همم
فبالتالي هتعرف بعد كده تختار صح
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينظم الينا كل من المحاميه
المختصه في قضايا الاسره رشا صبري
والكاتبه والاعلاميه نهال علام اهلا بكما
ابدا معك سيد رشا هناك من يعتبر ان النساء
العازبات في نعمه من نقمه الزواج السيء او
الحياه الزوجيه غير الناجحه وغير السعيده
ما رايكم اولا في هذه الرؤيا
والله انا رايي ان انا متفقه جدا
العروسه المفروض
كويس جدا احسن مختار جواز فاشل ينتج عنه
ابناء يتربى في ظروف قاسيه او الام تتحمل
مسؤوليه كامله في ظل قوانين ما بقتش
بتساعد المراه بشكل قوي انها تاخذ
مصاريف لاولادها كويسه بعد الطلاق تسمح
لها انها تقدر تعيشهم كويس او تعلمهم كويس
فنتج عن الجواز الخطا لما بينتج عنده اسره
تدمرت واولاد
مستقبلهم بقى مجهول وبقى مبهم فطبعا انا
من الانصار ان العنوسه او ما اسمهاش علوسه
هي البنت من غير جواز مش همم مش بتختار ده
مش اختيار سيء ده انسان اختارت راحتها
ونجاحها وحوريتها بدل ما تضيع حياتها
وتتمنى الموت في جواز ما كانش ينفع انها
تكمل فيه فانا من انصار
رشا لما تقولي البنت اختارت راحتها
وحريتها يعني كمان لا ينطبق على كل
الزيجات يعني قد تكون المراه متزوجه
ولديها الراحه الكافيه ولديها ايضا الحريه
الكافيه
احنا بنتكلم على نسبه كبيره للاسف
فيها مجتمع بشكل مجتمعي مش بشكل اا قايم
على المشاعر وقائم على الاختيار الحر
للاسف يعني حضرتك بتتكلمي كما لو كانت هي
اختارت اختيار حر احنا بنتكلم على الحالات
اللي بيتم فيها قهرها وهمم ومجرد ما بتوصل
لسن معين بيتم تزوجها بالذات في الريف او
في الصعيد او في في الاماكن اللي هي
البسيطه فاحنا ما بنتكلمش عن البنت اللي
هي بتعمل لك حوريه الاختيار وبتعمل همم
وبترتبط بزوج سوي بيعملها معامله سوريه
احنا بنتكلم عن غالبيه العظمى للاسف اللي
انا الحاله اللي باحكي لك عنها من القضايا
اللي بتجيء لي ومن اللي انا باشوفه انه
الغالبيه العظمى اتجوزوا لمجرد الجواز
والهرب من لقب ناسها يعني طيب طيب
هل بالفعل انت مع الراجل اللي بيقول
العزوبيه المراه انا حامل
غير مرتاحه فيه
حلقتكم النهارده وهي بالفريق المغربي وهي
لعبه كره القدم لو لعبه كره القدم نزل
الفريق فيها مش 11 فرد هل كنا هنتوقع نشوف
يعني
الانجاز اللي بيحصل في اي مكان او فيه اي
ماتش كوره بيتلعب لا واذا اضطر الفريق ان
هو يلعب بعدد اقل من الموجودين فيه ما
بتكونش المباراه بيلعب وبتستمر اللعبه
وبتنتهي ولكن مش بتكون المباراه في افضل
حالتها اذا ده اللي بيرجعنا للعبه الحياه
لعبه الحياه كمان لها قواعد ولها شروط من
اهم شروط لعبه الحياه هي الزواج الزواج هو
مؤسسه اقدم مؤسسه عرفتها البشريه جمعاء
مؤسسه الزواج مهم هو مهم للغايه لا تستمر
الحياه طبعا بشكلها البيولوجي وشكلها
العددي وكل المبادئ اللي احنا عارفينها
ولكنه ايضا مهم علشان تستمر نفس حياه
الانسان تستمر المشاع وتستمر العلاقات
سيدنا ادم كانت له جنه كلها ولكن ربنا
اداله حواء علشان يستمتع ولما حر من الجنه
ونزل على الارض مكانتش دي اكبر مشاكله لو
كان عايش على الجنه لوحده الونس والدفا
والاجتمال والاكتمال بيتم هو ده شكل
الحياه حتى مش بس في البشر في البشر وفي
الحيوانات وفي كل حال
يعني عمقتي بالفكره بس انا بدي اعرف شو
تعريفك لا الزواج
هو مؤسسا بتكتمل فيها مشاعر الاثنين
بيكملوا بعض الاثنين بياخذوا حياتهم
وبيمضوا بها قدوما الى الافضل والى الاحسن
لو انا محدده ان انا عايزه اسافر في رحله
الماء او في وجه الماء وعرفت ان الطياره
اللي انا حركبها دي هتقع فيها مشاكل ثانيه
اكيد مش حركه بالطياره لكن مش حال غير
رحله هادور على طياره ثانيه تكون افضل
توديني وجهتي احنا المشكله عندنا همم ان
احنا يعني ودي كانت مشكله في ال- في
الاوقات اللي قبل دي ان الواحد الاختيار
يختار ازاي احنا ما بنتناقش في فكره
الزواج وكلمه عانس وكلمه عازب والكلمات دي
على نفس هي فعلا عربي جايه من العنص وهي
الكوبرا هي الامراه او الرجل مش بس المراه
اللي بتوقوا كبار على عدم الزواج ولكن
اعتقد النهار ده فعل الجبر ما بقاش موجود
الجبر ده حتى في القواعد المجتمعيه لو
قلنا الاقتصاديه او غيره لا النهارده
البنت لها كلمه
مع احترامي زميلتي رشا ولكن البنت ليها
كلمه في المجتمعات الريفيه وفي المجتمعات
الاكثر تهميشا لا المراه لها كلمه لان على
كل المستويات النهار ده المراه اللاعب
اساسي في المجال الاقتصادي فتقدر تقول
ليها كلمه هل في بعض السيدات ما لهمش قله
قليله جدا لا يقاس عليها الكل طيب السيده
رشه مسمعنا نهال المشكله اليوم ليست في
الزواج ولكن في الاختيار هل تعتقدين انه
فكره الزواج اختلفت مع الاشياء يعني من
المجتمع على الثاني هل بالفعل المراه صار
يسمع رايها وهل تفضلي بدك شيء
الاستاذ يا استاذه نهال مع احترامي جدا
رايها انا اصلا من
منشات من منشئي من منشا ريفي وانا دول
اهلي ودول معارفي والناس اللي انا اعرفهم
وعارفه ازاي الجواز بيخضع للعادات
والتقاليد وقد يصل للاجبار وده مش فئه
بسيطه زي ما هي بتقول ولا حاجه بالعكس دي
فئه كبيره جدا واحنا لو جينا نبص لنسبه
الطلاق نسبه تعنيف المراه المتزوجه او من
اهلها فلق النسبه كبيره جدا في المجتمعات
الرفايه او في الصعيد او خلافه المجتمعات
اللي هي مش في مش في المدينه مثلا يعني ف
بالعكس انا دلوقت شايفه لو الجواز دلوقت
حالات الطلاق بقت منتشره جدا حالات ال همم
الامهات اللي بتجري عشان تجيب حقوق
اولادها بقت كبيره جدا الازواج الغير
مسئوله
جدا فانا شايفه لو الجواز هيوصلني في
الاخر لكارثه تضيع مستقبلي وتضيع حياتي
وتاثر على حياه اطفال ثانيين يجوا انا
كمان مستقبلهم يتاثر معي بسبب سوء اختياري
يبقى للاسف مش بعمل كارثه اثارها بتقع علي
لوحدي لا دي بتقع على اسره كامله بتدمر
حياتي مستقبلا بتدمر طموحي مستقبلا مين
اللي قال لما زوجه بتخرج من زواج فاشل
بتبقى الابواب كلها مفتوحه عليها انها
تبدا من اول وجديد حياتها العمليه ان ال-
انها تكمل دراستها ناس كثيره جدا ثابت
التعليم عشان الزواج بالعكس احنا لازم
ننظر بعين العقل ان احنا الحياه مش ورديه
للدرجه دي الزواج بقى الراجل بيدور على
عروسه تقدر تساعد معه في في اساسيات
الزواج والبنت بتدور على راجل عنده بيت او
يقدر يتجوز يدور هل يصلح الزواج النهارده
والرحمه لكن لماذا هذه النظاره السوداء
للزواج لماذا لا يكون الزواج هو ترجمه
اللي تفاهم لرغبه باين طرفين ان يكملها
المسار مع ان ينجحها ويكبر معا ويؤسسها
اسره ينجبها اولادنا وتكون في استمراريه
هنا في الحياه
هي مش نظره سوداويه على قد ما هي نظره
واقعيه انا في ازواج كثير ناجحين وانا ما
اقدرش اتجاهل الجزء ده من الحياه ان في
طبعا ناس ناجحه وفي ناس بس انا بتكلم على
الناس اللي اختاروا تجاربهم بوعيد دلوقتي
ابتدات نسبه العازبات تزيد مش هقول لعوانس
اسمها عزبات او ناس اختاروا بعض ارادتهم
ان هم ما يتجوزوش الا اذا لقوا الشخص
المناسب اما في حاله ان هم لقوا الشخص
المناسب فيبقى الجواز فعلا جنه انما لو
انا باتجوز لمجرد الجواز والمجرد ان انا
اعمل اسره فاحيانا بيبقى التخبط ما بين ان
انا باجبر اثنين من ثقافات مختلفه فان هم
يندمجوا مع بعض ده بيعمل مشاكل كتير
وحضرتك عارفه كلامك كويس انا مش باقول
كلام مثلا بشكل عشوائي انا باقول كلام جاي
من محض قضايا بتبقى منظوره قدامي الناس لو
ما عندهاش قبول من الاول للطرف اللي هي
بترتبط به للاسف ما بتقدرش تكمل للاسف
بيحصل طلاء مهما اكبر نفسها مهما الاهلي
اجباروها تكمل هتجيء لحظه وكل ده اتهد
للاسف وانا باحكي من واقع قضايا منظوره
قدامي وانا شايفاها فمش باحكي ومن- ومن
انماط مختلفه ومن شخصيات مختلفه وابقى
اساليب مختلفه فللاسف نظرتي واقعيه اكثر
جدا بالدليل زياده نسبه الطلاق حضرتك
بتتكلمي على اللي اختاره بمحض ارادتهم ان
هم يظلوا عزات اما بقى اللي اختارت بعد ما
تجوزت تخرج من الزواج ده للاسف الاثار
السيئه اللي بتنتج عن هذا القرار اسوا
بكثير من ان اختار العزوبيه بمحضراتي انا
باحكي بلحظه
اخر ردا عليك رشا انه هل هذا لديك لترد
الحقيقه يعني ان مش معنى ان الواحد بيخطئ
في التجربه مره معناها ان يعزف عن التجربه
بعد كده لا مش معنى اختياراتنا الغلط ان
احنا ما بنكررش الحاجات ثاني ولو اخذتك
برده للحياه لو رحتي مطعم وطلع وحش مش
هتخشي مطاعم في حياتك ثاني لا هتروحي بس
هتغيري الطريقه اللي بتفكري بها احنا
النهارده عايشين في مجتمعات مفتوحه عايشين
في يعني عندنا التكنولوجيا تقدر تساعدنا
كثير اذا طرق الاختيار نفسها اتغيرت انا
بس عايزه اعقب على كلمه قالتها رشا وهي
فكره ان الثقافات المختلفه بما انك محاميه
وموجوده في يعني زي ما قلت في يعني قصور
رفيه وموجوده مع النسبه دي هي ثقافات
متشابهه اللي ممكن تحصل فيها المشكله يبقى
اذا ما فيش ثوابت ممكن اثنين يكونوا من
نفس البيت وما يقدروش يعيشوا مع بعض وممكن
اثنين يكونوا من جنسيات مختلفه تماما
ويعيشوا ويعملوا حياه جميله جدا العلاقات
الانسانيه علاقات نسبيه لا يمكن تطبيق
فيها المطلق من واحد زائد واحد يساوي
اثنين لا يمكن ربنا خلق لنا بصمات في
ايدينا خاصنا بيها كل واحد ليه بصمه غير
الثاني في الثمانيه مليار اللي موجودين
على الارض وبالمثل خلق الاسمر نفسيه وبصمه
عقليه وبصمه روحيه لكل شخص فينا غير
الثاني ازاي نستغل ده وازاي نعرف ده هي دي
الغلطه اللي وقع فيها السابقون بقى ان
احنا ما كانش الناس بتبقى عارفه نفسها
بالاول علشان اعرف اختار شريك حياتي انا
لو فهمت نفسي كويس قوي وعرفت احدد رغباتي
هاعرف اختار شريك حياتي النهارده البنات
اللي عايزه تتجو او عايزه انها تشتغل او
عايزه انها تتعلم ده اختيارها هي اختيارها
لو هي اختارت انها تشتغل هتشتغل بعد
الجواز بس ما كانتش الشروط دي بتتحط واضحه
في الاول ههه لان هي ما كانتش فاهمه عن
نفسها انا ممكن تبقى محبه قوي انها تشتغل
بالشكل ده الناس اللي عايزه تتعلم ممكن
تقول لك اه انا اقدر اسيب تعليمي هي مش
غلطه الراجل لان انت بعد ما قررتي تسيبي
تعليمي وتروحي معها في المؤسسه وانا هارجع
ثاني
فكره ان الجواز مؤسسه لما بنشتغل في اي
مؤسسه مش لها شروط عدد معين من الساعات هل
بعد ما باشتغل بيجيء اقول له انا عايزه
بدل ال 10 ساعات لاخليهم لي ثمانيه هيقول
لي لا بالمتر الجواز لو من الجواز من
الاول بنكون واضحين في شروطنا وبنقول انا
عايزه اتعلم انا عايزه اشتغل انا اولوياتي
كذا وانت اولوياتك ايه اذا هنوصل لنقطه
التفاهم اللي بعد كده ما حدش هيقدر ان هو
يعني يرجع في اتفاق او لو رجع هيبقى طبعا
ودان وهيبقى غلطان وهيبقى شخص مش مضبوط من
الاول فالوضوح مهم جدا والوضوح قبل ما
اكون واضحه في الشخص الثاني اكون واضحه مع
نفسي انا طلباتي ايه من الجواز او من ده
ولو رجعت من حضراتكم للارقام اللي انتم
عملتوها وهي مثلا ارقام همم العزوف عن
الجواز ما بين اللبنانيات اللبنانيات
مثقفات وعلى قدر كبير من الجمال وعلى قدر
كبير من الوعي وعلى قدر كبير من كل الامور
اللي بالشكل ده ولكن ليه العزوف عن الزواج
لان كل منطقه من الدول العربيه اللي
حضراتكم ذكرتوها هي منطقه زيها خصوصيه اه
في عامل اقتصادي طبعا ما بنقدرش نقول
عليها والحمل اللي حضراتكم عرضتوها في
الاول وهي همم تزوجني دي حمله بتدعم فكره
الجواز طب اللبنانيه ناقصها ايه علشان
تعمل حمله زي دي ناقصها الاجتماعي اه
باكتمل الراجل بيكتمل بالمراه والمراه
بتكتمل بالرجل دي قاعده مش هنقدر نخرج
عنها ارتفعت بقى نسب الطلاق ارتفعت نسب
همم العزوف عن الجواز لو مش عايزين نستخدم
لفظ العنوسه ولو ان اللفظ اللي احنا لازم
نحطه برده احنا اللي حطيناه له صوره وحشه
العازف هو العازف ولكن اللي فيه الجبر هو
فكره العنوسه ولكن نرجع ثاني لما ارجع بقى
بعد كده في سنتين والتقارير لو ما حضراتكم
بالفعل الناس ارتفعت فيه جدا جدا عن ما تم
رصده في 2018 لكن ما ننساش ان كان في ازمه
تبقى بقى كرونه اللي عدت الناس في البيت
وخلت العلاقات نفسها والتواصل ما بين
الناس وبعضها وقاعده اتذكر يعني كان في
هنا سيده في مصر او فتاه في مصر طلعت في
وقتنا
طلبت على صفحتها على الفيسبوك وقالت انا
عايزه اتجوز انا الكرونه قعدتنا في البيت
وانا ما باشوفش حد وطبيعي مش هتبقى مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هي الفكره الرائجه ان
الناس يعني تتجوز من عليها وايه باذن ده
برده بيدعم فكره الجواز وفكره الاجتماع
طبعا خرجنا منها على بقى يعني المنحنى
الاصداء ليه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وكل
تضعيات الاقتصاديه في العالم اكيد فكره
الاقتصاد بتخلي الناس
فبالتالي نتوقع هذا الاسترسال والكلام
الطويل منك ونشكرك جزيلا شكرا انتهى الوقت
للاسف وايضا نشكر ضيفتنا نهال ونختهم معكم
ما بانه ليه الزواج كل منا له راي في هذا
الزواج وبالتالي في نعم همم بالعزوبيه وفي
ايضا نقمات كما في نعم في الزواج وفي
نقابات ففي كل شيء يعني ينبسطوا وعيشوا
حياتكم في كل مرحله الطريقه المثلى شكرا
لكم